gleich neben dem berühmten kölner dom
liegt die hohenzollernbrücke
sie verbindet die beiden rheinufern
hunderte züge und tausende fußgänger
überqueren sie täglich doch sie ist
nicht nur ein praktischer verkehrsweg
sondern auch eine kultstätte für
liebende zehntausende vorhängeschlösser
zieren die südseite der brücke und
täglich kommen neue hinzu
event akademie und olga romantik haben
sich heute hier verabredet
die beiden kölner sind seit drei jahren
ein paar gemeinsam befestigen sie am
gelände einschloss mit ihrem
eingravierten namen die schlüssel werfen
sie in den rhein
ihr wunsch dass die liebe ewig hält
zumindest unsere liebe wer man ist schon
hier auf der brücke verewigen kann dann
hält die liebe auch schlossfest das
hoffen viele paare und zwar nicht nur in
köln sondern auf der ganzen welt in
paris hängen die sogenannten
liebesschlösser auf dem podest
es gibt sie in prad genau wie in moskau
wo sie an bäumen befestigt werden
ähnlich wie in der koreanischen
hauptstadt zogen in china findet man sie
vor allem entlang der chinesischen mauer
ein phänomen mit dem sich mittlerweile
auch die wissenschaft beschäftigt
die ethnologin dagmar hänel beginnt 2008
die liebesschlösser zu erforschen
bei ihrer suche nach der herkunft des
brauches die sich schnell auf die
zahlreichen beispiele aus china der
handel sei wirklich gedacht bin wo das
ist der ursprung das ist das religiöses
und eine alte asiatische tradition
vielleicht mussten dann aber relativ
schnell feststellen dass die von
westlichen touristen dahin gehängt
wurden das ist eine alte tradition ist
es wurde dann relativ schnell klar dass
diese liebesschlösser ein ganz typisches
ritual unserer globalisierten
mediengesellschaft sind so dass man gar
nicht mehr genau sagen kann wo ist es
eigentlich entstanden
es geht rasend schnell dass es weltweit
auf pop und aufgegriffen wird
viele sehen ihn als den begründer des
brauches der italienische schriftsteller
federico macheda in seinem bestseller
vol at t von 2006 beschreibt er das
schlüssel ritual auf dem konto in rom
für mehr authentizität traf er damals
eine kleine vorkehrung
an dem abend bevor das buch erschien bin
ich hier auf die brücke gekommen
ich habe eine kette befestigt und
anschluss daran gehängt und zwar an der
dritten laterne so wie ich es im buch
beschrieben hatte kurz darauf kommt die
liebesgeschichte von stefan genever in
die kinos sie wird 2007 zu einem der
erfolgreichsten filme in italien und
liefert millionen verliebten eine
romantische vorlage
danach wird der ponte millio zum pilger
platz verliebte pärchen befestigen
tausende schlösser zum schutz der
historischen brücke lässt die stadt sie
aber immer wieder entfernen
doch die verliebten lassen sich nicht
aufhalten und suchen einen neuen ort für
ihre liebesschlösser eine
aussichtsplattform auf dem monte mario
nordwestlich von rom heute einer der
romantischsten plätze der italienischen
hauptstadt
für mich war diese ganze entwicklung
eine sehr große überraschung
ich finde es interessant wie eine sache
die so zum spaß entstanden ist plötzlich
zu einer mode zu einem regelrechten
mythos wird leute von überall her auch
aus dem ausland kommen her und machen
mit so sind es vermutlich auch touristen
die den brauch nach köln bringen
die rheinländer kultband de höhner trägt
2009 mit dem song schenk mir dein herz
zur verbreitung bei
ich nicht
die 5
seitdem steigt die nachfrage online
shops für individuell gravierte
vorhängeschlösser blumen sowie cologne
finest der einmann betrieb beliefert
mittlerweile kunden auf der ganzen welt
social media das facebook netzwerk über
twitter gehen das so schnell und dann in
die ganze welt heraus wo dann wirklich
alle altersgruppen dabei sind so scheint
die welt von glücklichen liebenden
bevölkert doch die zahlen sprechen eine
andere sprache in deutschland scheitert
jede dritte ehe
immer mehr menschen leben heute allein
experten vermuten gerade deswegen werden
deutliche zeichen für paare wichtiger
und zwar nicht nur als gegenseitiges
liebesbekenntnis wenn man das dann auf
hängt auf der brücke und das ist ein
öffentlicher raum da gehen jeden tag
über 1000 leute vorbei dann wird das
auch gleichzeitig das statement eines
paares gegen die gesellschaftliche
statistik nämlich dass das beziehung
halt eben nicht unbedingt das leben lang
halten und das ist ein statement für die
anderen für die gesellschaft die sagt
wir lieben und so das wird funktionieren
und das wird halten
davon sind all die pärchen auf der
kölner hohenzollernbrücke überzeugt
viele kommen jedes jahr wieder hierher
um ihren liebesschwur zu erneuern und
event akademie und organische bewerfen
sicherheitshalber auch noch den
ersatzschlüssel in den rhein